we got big news deadline reports the
daily wire is making a liveaction Snow
White movie starring conservative
YouTuber Brett Cooper watch the teaser
uh it's for their I think bent key is
their children's streaming service
conservative Media Company daily wies
making its own live action adaptation of
the brothers Grim fairy tale Snow White
called Snow White and the evil queen the
film which is set to release in 2024
will be the first featurelength
production of the company's kids
entertainment platform called bent key
which will star Brett Cooper host of the
platform show the comment section they
have the trailer here uh you can watch
it I I don't I don't want to play or
maybe we should how was it did you watch
it it's really short I'll just I'm just
going to play it because I think it's
news
relevant Once Upon A
[Music]
Time In Time a prince would
come this Cooper singing yes upon a time
but now that time is
[Music]
gone okay I'm really excited but I only
have one issue I don't think they should
have cast Brett Cooper yeah I because uh
I just feel like if you're a political
commentator and personality trying to
push you into scripted and fiction is
just kind of like you know like for Ian
it kind of makes sense because he's not
a political commentator personality he
is an actor first and it's kind of
obvious in the way he views politics no
offense but I think people understand
he's not this is not his main thing but
then when they watch him do like the
bits and the shorts and the cast Castle
stuff they're like wow he knows how to
act well well yeah it's like that's his
thing mhm but I will say what's really
funny about this is is you know Disney's
putting out their new Snow White and
they're doing this like Snow White and
the Seven Companions thing right where
they got rid of the dwarfs because Peter
Dinklage didn't want anyone any other
dwarfs to have job and then other dwarf
people were like why are you ruining
rules for us we were going to get so
ridiculous especially when you look at
the Wizard of Oz and how all of those
dwarves got to meet each other and start
families and fall in love and stuff like
the hell Peter Dinklage yeah he's like
but I will I will say Brett Cooper fits
the role substantially better than
Rachel zler or Zigler whatever her name
is she also probably likes it better I
mean Rachel Ziggler hates the role yeah
hates the story but like I'm I'm
actually really interested to watch the
Disney version I I I haven't had Disney
plus since that uh uh uh the the
Concentration Camp thing they supported
so I'm just like yeah I'm not going to
concentration you mean the Gina corano
thing no Disney plus thanked the uh
security forces in uh was it in shinjang
y yeah where where where the
Mulan yeah and I was like um that's
creepy you we'll see ourselves out I'm
like Disney does a lot of things that I
think are cringe and woke and I always
tell people like yeah but I don't expect
everyone to just cancel all of their uh
got s b they cancel all their
entertainment right away we need to
create Alternatives but like when they
thank the security forces that are
enforcing like that we acknowledge as a
genocide like you know I'm just not
going to give you any money but uh but
anyway I'm really interested despite all
that to how they handle the Seven
Companions like which one's going to be
like Dopey and Doc and you know what I
mean oh they're probably going to be
like woki and you know they them
and do you remember when Marvel tried
doing like the new mutons I think it was
and they had Snowflake and safe space
were two of the characters they made yes
this is what they're going to do with
them they can't they can't insult people
by calling them Sneezy that's that's
that's ableist why didn't they do uh
Snow White in the polycule oh and she's
like I think too racy for them they
likey have you seen the people in these
polycules they're not racy particularly
I'm just saying Mage that's too far send
a message to Ashley St Clair she's at
the Babylon B and I think that we should
do this Ashley if you're out there snow
white will be it's a morbidly obese
woman and she's got a bunch of guys all
around her and she's like I don't need a
prince cuz I've got all this and the
guys are like we're happy and the guys
are mostly trans they're mostly trans
and would the wicked Queen be hot as
opposed to the snow in
this like her sister like's weird I have
legit question about about how daily
wire is doing Snow White are they going
to make it's Snow White and the evil
queen okay is the evil queen going to be
a communist and I don't mean like
literally like they make a movie and the
queen walks out and she's got like a
sickle you know hammer or whatever but
is it going to be an analogy for merit
and Independence and the evil queen is
jealous communism right I certainly hope
that the evil queen is vain and power
hungry yeah that like she's supposed to
she's supposed to be I don't understand
why we would take what they should do
they should be like the evil queen
retains Power by telling all of the
suffering people that she's actually
helping them and that it's better this
way and then Snow White is like no no
lift yourselves up work hard and defeat
the evil queen I hope it's a story about
uh individualism and is not involved in
the political realm at all yeah I hope
it's about vanity and uh struggles of
aging and youth I don't know that it has
to be tied to political ideology and the
value of of love over seeking to
dominate your opposition there is a part
in the original Disney Snow White that
haunts me to this day it's when Snow
White's baking her pie and then she
looks up and it just has the wicked
Queen in the window and has the old lady
and it just it's nightmare fuel this
this is crazy look at this daily wire
says bent key will be available at
launch with 150 episodes of 18 shows
including four bent key Originals new
episodes are due to arrive every
Saturday morning so Saturday morning
cartoons so we we're talking about what
we're trying to do and it's
substantially smaller than what the
daily wire is doing but uh we're
launching the coffee shop Cas Brew up in
everyone probably knows where it is now
Marburg and we're going to do the anti
Time Square but the main reason we want
to do it is not that we think we're
going to get super wealthy off having a
coffee shop it's that Saturday mornings
are when we invite families to come in
for a CED breakfast with their kids and
you know what we'll do we'll uh we'll
play the wi's cartoons cuz we know
they're new and they're going to be good
for families and kids and of course I'll
talk to the Daily wire first I just rip
their content and play it for everybody
but I'm sure they they'll be cool you
should probably just rip their content
and play it for everybody there's
literally no reason I'm sure if I asked
J me I was like hey we want to play
Saturday morning your Saturday morning
cartoons for families at our coffee shop
he'd be like please like tell them to
tell their friends thing that they did
this for kids and I really wish them the
best with it I hope that they have a lot
of success uh there's we've been starved
for contest like that for our children
so I really really appreciate it so
thank you guys I mean look Brett Cooper
is probably really good in this role she
fits the role better than Rachel Zigler
and she's got an amazing singing voice
I'm just kind of like you've already
she's a political commentator you know
she's transitioning back to acting that
was her origin right yeah she comes
she's coming from that to be a political
commentator so I think for me more than
anything I am kind of tired of the
remakes of you know Disney Classics and
all these things I'd be really curious
to see their original content they're
saying there's all these shows or if
they were to take some other folk tale
that has there's so many over the place
yeah there was like a a whole bunch of
stories from the um abanaki and alanin
tribes in New England yeah and they were
recorded there was this like what in the
18 whatevers you know this uh
Anthropologist went around and recorded
all of the stories from the Aging Native
Americans who were basically on their
way out they were like you know old
people dying the stories weren't going
to uh stories weren't going to last
forever and he wrote them all down and
then uh you know he published a book of
all of these fascinating stories like
there was this one about this woman who
um she lives with her parents and she
falls in love with this guy and she uh
her parents are like no no no he's a
terrible guy and then she runs away from
home to be with this guy and uh goes to
live with him and eventually her parents
go to find her and she's like all alone
by this Lake because it turns out she
married a sea serpent oh fascinating
fascinating there's all these stor start
embracing the there's the story of the
chu which is this like ice heart person
MH these are all fascinating stories and
of course this Anthropologist was like a
white guy from Harvard I'm pretty sure
and um his book has been widely
discredited because he was white and
stories God forbid right and they're
fascinating stories but I would love to
see also some of the other
Grim fairy tales yeah you know I think
that there's more content than we give
credit to and the fact that I get why
it's like oh we had this Rachel's eagler
thing so now we should make our own Snow
White but I'd actually like to see daily
wire just Embrace more expansive
American culture and the folktales that
come with both European and American
culture that we don't already have
because it's when they do their own
original stuff that's when I think
they're at their strongest I don't
really need to see another version of
Snow White and it would be great to have
more American Myth and Legend in our
daily you know content and storytelling
I would love that absolutely one of my
favorite uh I guess underrated fairy
tales is called Princess furball oh
that's cute yes it's it's adorable and
it's just about this this princess whose
family had passed and then she was
supposed to be sent away to go marry
some some like Troll and uh she was like
okay but you need to do this favor for
me I'm going to need three dresses one
is bright as the sun one as bright as
the moon and one as dark as the night
sky and she was able to
um and then she wanted a fur coat made
of the fur of a thousand different
animals and she she made all these
requests because she's like they're
never going to be able to to do this and
they they did it and the the king F coat
sounds really mean yes I know right p is
livid I would I would yeah so but anyway
get an one coat and then she shoves
these dresses which are these big
elaborate dresses into these Walnut
shells and uh puts them in her pocket
and then they find her so this other
Kingdom finds her cuz she runs away she
doesn't marry the troll she runs away
with her coat and
her Walnut suitcases right and they find
her so this other king finds her hiding
in like a a tree and they think she's an
animal because she's covered in this
coat of a thousand first and so they're
like oh and they realize she's a human
they're like oh well you can be a slave
in our kitchen she's like Okay cool so
she goes she's a slave in the kitchen
and then she decides she wants to sneak
away to the ball you know and that's I
don't want to spoil the end of Princess
furball for everybody but you know it it
gets it gets better than that so I would
I would do a princess bball that's
that's the thing there are so many cool
stories both you know written and you
know folklore that has passed down from
different cultures I'd love to just move
away from just recycling the same ones
that Disney already made I agree it's
it's cooler to see original stuff even
if we're remakes of Disney's
interpretations of the stories instead
of retellings of the original fables
there are remakes of redheads in Disney
there are just no redheads they get rid
of them well you're not AAL minority
daily wies got a redhe head on beny
that's not an original red
head uh no there's no way it's too
uniform this is their launch I
suppose there you go I don't know I just
fun maybe that maybe that's part of the
whole message like we're not going to
delete the redheads well you guys are a
genetic Global minority you I don't
understand why no one advocates for you
because because we're not we're not
wimps we don't we don't care that people
you know erase us we're like whatever
you should you should be louder about it
I don't think this cause gets enough
attention yeah the one thing I disagree
with is the Muppet oh I don't know if
you can legally call it a muppet cuz
it's like a protected term or whatever
but I've just never been a fan of like
the weird puppet things I don't like the
kids puppet shows Sesame Street fine I
guess whatever that one's a pupp the
cartoons I think are good I never knew a
cookie about fragle rock did you not
like Fraggle Rock I did not no you
didn't like fragle rock I despise
Muppets you despise I really really like
the Muppets I like I do like
I did like Fraggle Rock Miss Piggy is
just is just exists to make fun of Liz
Cheney but I'm not I am not insulting
with cheny I am saying that people cre
but I mean like that's the value of Miss
Piggy to mock someone like this Jing
it's really did you like Kermit when he
was in those car commercials that's what
I I didn't watch The Muppets growing up
but I do remember those car commercials
where it was always it was like for a
hybrid car and so they brought out watch
The Muppet Show on TV it was on TV oh
Kermit being green I get it yeah hybrid
Y and I think it was on during the
American Idol uh commercial breaks I
could be wrong but the Muppet Show was
on TV and it was I believe it was I
believe it was on Sunday nights yeah and
I watched it and the Muppet Show was
really cool because it was uh it was
like a it was like behind the scenes it
was like a live act it was like their
they were putting on a show and there
was scooter was the stage manager I
loved that that's fun see I think there
are there is space for original content
that's that's an example of original
content that you can't just be like so
we're going to make our own version of
Muppet Show that's essentially the same
thing like pick something new pick
something fresh because that's Muppet
babies and they they get all the
spin-offs I appreciate that so Star Wars
when when you load the website this is
what it looks
like I like chinchilla because it also
like when it loads it then jumps to a
thing like sign up now but this is what
it shows before showing the sign up now
oh is she reading a book about herself
is that what she's doing doing probably
I don't know she is is that her name
narcissism rampant wait a minute what
values are they promoting maybe she's
playing the evil queen and that's the
vanity and the power hungry she redhead
too though I know unfortunately but I
guess I guess one of my questions too is
like so a lot of the cartoons for kids
are they don't really teach lessons it's
just kind of kids entertainment so it's
silly like Fairly Odd Parents yeah so
it's like not in it's not inappropriate
for the kids but it's also not
educational I'm wondering if are going
for more Educational Learning life
lessons you know I think that I I don't
think that all entertainment needs that
stuff and I don't think that it should
be inorganically I do like there are the
undertones like um Jack bobic wrote that
book about the island of ice cream and
it I I have that book but it's it's got
all these undertones about why
meritocracy is good why communism is bad
and and but it doesn't read that way to
a child but to parent I like his book
too yes it's wonderful but I like see
stories organically have a morality to
them as opposed to have it be the
morality is the reason you're making the
story like you want it to be part of the
narrative intentionally yeah more
Blended more Blended and not about like
I have an ideological perspective and
now I'm going to make a cartoon
listening right I was listening to this
whole thing about um I was doing so you
know Israel war whatever I don't know
very much about Israel I don't know very
much about any of it so I started doing
like some research research and digging
into it and Hamas had this um children's
show where it was about it was basically
teaching children that the best thing
they can do in life is be jihadis oh my
goodness but makes sense why wouldn't
they make that as well they did make
that and so the first main character
died as a Jihadi and they had like can
you know they him more characters after
that of children giving their lives to
be jihadis that's crazy and that was
that was on TV in Gaza wow I mean it's
it's not like so in you Christian face
there there's Martyrs you know but but
we don't we don't preach that like it is
good to be a martyr here's a show about
Martyrs and you're going to be a martyr
and these children are martyring so it's
it's just weird the way that it's
presented in this way well it was a
shift too like from the research I've
done anyway you know it was a shift in
the uh it became like a far it was a
extremist
Islamic um group right so it wasn't like
you're you're just everyday Muslims it
became this extremist idea that
infiltrated incrementally and then
eventually what they started to do was
like when Hamas was founded in like ' 88
and they started attacks in ' 89 and it
kept going but then they started
providing and then they won the election
you know against like what F I think it
was but they um they started providing
all these Social Services because I was
like why did the people of Gaza elect
Hamas to lead them in 2006 after Israel
Israel withdrew why did they do that and
so I was trying to figure that out too
and it was because Hamas was providing
all of these Social Services they were
providing schools and hospitals and all
of these things and so they offered this
big promise but the promise comes with
this horrific price I have a friend who
lived under the Taliban and uh this is
this is uh probably 6 seven eight years
ago now but he would write me and he
tell me all the good things that the
Taliban did for them and a lot of Social
Services ma did things too other than
that's how you win supporters right you
offer them what they need right and I
mean if you know the lessons of CH Gua
tell us anything it's that like if
you're going to do this kind of
Revolution and take control you need the
support of the people to do it exactly
definitely and the people think they
depend on you and you kind of look at
the social programs in America and it
kind of answers all the questions and
then you start to wonder too like what
are you know what we've given up in
return for those social programs is
pretty extreme thankfully not as extreme
I think going but ours were faced in
over time so people became it's
incremental me and um me and Jack pic
were talking about this the
incrementalism of evil Y and like how
itep they let you become comfortable the
more migrants that we have here the more
social programs we're going to need and
the more Reliant people come so it's
it's definitely a trickle it's and we
had a yeah we had a writer at at human
events who did a deep dive and comparing
all of the different things um of what
Jihad is and like comparing it to the
Quran and like digging into different
translations and she's kind of this
crazy genius actually um but uh the
first the first stage of jihad is when
you're Islamic and you're a minority in
the culture and you just normalize Your
Existence you like say that you're just
really nice and all of this stuff and
then it's just this incremental approach
um it's really terrifying to look at
some of these ideologies of like total
hatred of the other and how it morphs
and takes over yeah some of the Hadith
are just literally written about that
almost exactly just about being against
somebody else and about like how you're
to struggle against this person because
that's what it means the word means
struggle so that's a better way to look
at it but you're you're right all that
stuff yeah it's really crazy thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net